- Dude, I'm starving.
Pizza!
- Aw, yes!
- We deserve it.
- You aren't ordering take out are you?
- Yeah, why?
- I just bought all those groceries.
There is plenty of food here.
- So much effort, you know?
- Thai food?
- Pretty sure it'll be cold
by the time it gets here.
- Sure, with that attitude.
Plus, I like it better cold.
- Alright, you know what?
Whatever, I'm pulling the trigger, okay?
- This delivery minimum is pretty steep
for one person though.
- You could just go walk to pick it up.
Tubby?
- Brain bubble!
Stay with me.
Or, you could add an
appetizer, drink, and desert.
- You could stick to that diet
that you've been preaching about
on Instagram for awhile now
- I unfollowed you.
- I got it, right here, sushi.
I'm having sushi.
No delivery fee, 1.7 miles away.
- No, it's always under a cost.
- You will be hungry again in an hour.
- Oh my god, okay, I'm going
to starve to death then.
We're going back to pizza.
I am ordering pizza!
- So, order the cheap pizza?
Which will take what,
25 minutes to get here?
Or, you can order the good
pizza, that will take,
roughly 90 minutes, regardless
of what time you order.
- Guys, I am so hungry.
(iPhone text message)
- Ouu, Michelle.
Yeah, where were you thinking?
Not full smiley-face emoji
but like the, that one.
Send.
(iPhone text message)
- Alright you've got to wine
her and you've got to dine her.
- Alright, I'm gonna give
you the top 10 places
that I would take a girl, ready?
- Michelle is a special lady.
- Drum roll please, hit it.
- Don't nickname her Michelle My Belle,
because she's heard that.
- Alright, no drum roll.
- You need to come up
- Fuddruckers,
- with something new like
- good weekday spot.
- "Michelle, you're swell."
- Chili's, good weekend spot.
- Huh? It doesn't even have to rhyme.
- Maybe just "Michelle, 'sup?"
- Applebee's, after 10...